[Music]
now for the second time in 18 months
President Trump will make a decision
that will impact our country for decades
and yes for generations with Justice
Anthony Kennedy now retiring the
president is now tasked with picking his
replacement a task he does not take
lightly
nor should he take a look from earlier
today he's been a great Justice of the
Supreme Court he he is a man who is
displaying great vision he's displayed
tremendous vision and tremendous heart
and he will be missed but he will be
retiring and we will begin our search
for a new Justice of the United States
Supreme Court that will begin
immediately we have a very excellent
list of great talented highly educated
highly intelligent hopefully tremendous
people I think the list is very
outstanding when I was running I I put
down a list of 20 people because not
being a politician I think people wanted
to hear what some of my choices may be
and it was pretty effective and I think
you see the kind of quality that we're
looking at when you look at that list
but I did add I added five additional
people to the list so it will be
somebody from that list I want to take a
minute by the way for all of you never
Trump errs and you all know who you are
I'm thinking about naming names but not
tonight I do have a message for you if
you had your way remember we'd say the
Supreme Court is at stake that alone
means everything Hillary Rodham Clinton
now would be making this now a second
appointment in the terms of the judicial
course of American history which would
alter this country country for decades
to come it's time to admit a lot of you
how wrong you are about Donald Trump
although I'm not going to hold my breath
tonight so as the president has
mentioned many times he is committed to
picking from a solid list of qualified
originalist justices who have a proven
track record of holding the Constitution
not legislating from the
bench people whose judicial philosophy
is one that believes in separation of
powers co-equal branches a government
now sadly this is the exact opposite of
what Democrats and people like Hillary
would want instead the left they want
judges who even value insight
international law not our own
Constitution people that would legislate
from the bench people that believe in
this evolving interpretation that means
nothing of our Constitution what the
left can never accomplish through the
ballot box or through real legislation
they actually try to accomplish by
abusing the court system and using
activist judges to accomplish all their
left-wing dreams and ideology now make
no mistake as soon as the president taps
whoever Anthony Kennedy's replacement
will be you're going to witness the
single most contentious nasty vicious
dirty propaganda character assassination
campaign it will be one of the most
contentious political battles in decades
tonight your news media is already going
there so in light of today's breaking
news yes it's time for another Hannity
history lesson to bring you this time it
involves just how desperate and low
Democrats will go and literally malign
the character of good decent smart
people and what they plan to do to the
president's next Supreme Court nominee
whoever it ends up being they will try
to destroy them let's start with the
outgoing Justice Anthony Kennedy now for
30 years Kennedy he's accumulated what
is a very mixed track record nominated
by Ronald Reagan to 1988 many have
referred to him as the courts swing
justice
he saved Roe versus Wade from being
overturned he upheld the use of
affirmative action extended legal rights
to foreign terrorists at Gitmo but
Kennedy also voted to kill Obamacare
preserve Second Amendment rights and
most recently he voted to uphold the
president's travel ban it's kind of
weird because he he never had a judicial
philosophy that he seemed to adhere to
like Justice Thomas or Justice Scalia or
Justice Alito and now with President
Trump poised to nominate what he has
said he would do in the campaign a
strict originalist to replace the very
unpredictable kennedy democrats are
now sharpening their Spears just like
they did back in 1987 let's go down
memory lane now before Reagan nominated
Anthony Kennedy to the Supreme Court he
did tap somebody who was a judicial
genius he tapped a strict constitutional
originalist his name was Judge Robert
Bork and hell-bent on preventing Robert
Bork from becoming a Supreme Court
justice Senate Democrats engaged in one
of the most disgusting smear campaigns
which culminated on the Senate floor
without right lies from Senator Ted
Kennedy watch how low they can go take a
look Robert Bork's America is a land of
which women would be forced into
back-alley abortions blacks would sit at
segregated lunch counters rogue police
could break down citizen's doors and
midnight raids and school children could
not be taught about evolution writers
and artists would be censored at the
whim of government all lies all attempts
to scare intimidate the American people
now after what you just saw Democrats
were able to actually block the
nomination that's how we now have ended
up with the term being born which by the
way the Oxford English Dictionary
describes as quote obstructs someone by
systematically defaming or vilifying
them let's fast forward a couple of
years later the confirmation of now
Supreme Court Justice Clarence Thomas
during his Senate hearings this goes
back to 1991 Democrats rolled out his
former colleague Anita Hill to make
sexual harassment allegations against
him the process became so vicious and
nasty just as Thomas and what is now
infamous famous comments he referred to
it as a high-tech lynching watch this
this is a circus it's a national
disgrace
and from my standpoint as a black
American as far as I'm concerned it is a
high-tech lynching for uppity blacks who
in any way deign to think for themselves
to do for themselves to have different
ideas and it is a message that unless
you count to an old order this is what
will happen to you you will be lynched
destroyed caricatured by a committee of
the u.s. US Senate rather than hung from
a tree Wow
powerful floral marks you know character
assassination look at just the last week
and what's happening and what has been
said and what has being said about women
and secretary Nielsen and Pam Bondi and
and so many others and Ivanka and
Melania and Sarah Sanders by the way if
you want to read one of the best books
you'll ever read it's written by
Clarence Thomas it's called my
grandfather's son now if you think what
you saw is bad it's about to get
actually probably worse with the
ideological makeup of the Supreme Court
now hanging in the balance after
President Trump successfully nominated
originalist Neel Gorsuch to the court
Senate Democrats are about to pull out
all stops they'll do and say anything
just like Ted Chappaquiddick Kennedy to
block Donald Trump's pick now we're not
even a day out from Justice Kennedy's
announcement in the left is already in
full on total freakout panic scare the
American people mode and full on lying
mode watch this are you guys ready to
may be rip up some of the rules that
have as Rachel said limited Democrats
yes the : I know we're ready for the
fabric of our democracy Democrats should
dig in for art here into everything they
conceivably can do to block this
nomination any nomination for going
forward our Republican colleagues in the
Senate should follow the rule they set
in 2016 not to consider a Supreme Court
justice in an election
year it's time for Democrats to throw
down and what I mean by that is that
we've been playing by the rulebook and
Donald Trump and Republicans have been
playing by street rules we need to play
by street rules don't allow a vote on
this don't have a hearing don't have a
meeting don't let anything go forward
don't play ball with this decision
merely a preview of coming attractions
at this massive rally tonight in Fargo
North Dakota the president previewed
this looming battle and so much more
let's take a look at what he had to say
a very special guy also just announced a
little while ago his retirement from the
United States Supreme Cal
great man and I'm very honored that he
chose to do it during my term in office
because he felt confident in me to make
the right choice and carry on his great
legacy that's why he did Democrats want
judges who will rewrite the Constitution
any way they want to do it and take away
your Second Amendment
erase your borders throw open the
jailhouse doors and destroy your
freedoms we must elect more republicans
we have to do that we need more
Republicans especially in the Senate we
have to hold the house and maybe even
increase it and I think we'll be able to
do it they keep talking about this blue
wave there blue wave is really
sputtering pretty badly the red wave is
happening just look what happened last
night so be the most important midterm
election in our lifetime it's that
profound as the president now gains
political momentum and builds an
impressive track record accomplishments
I think we're the only show that shows
you them the Democratic Party is falling
apart the era of global freeloading the
president said is over an example last
night a 28 year old socialist from New
York defeated longtime Democratic
incumbent in a congressional primary
race as president from said tonight he
got his ass kicked and many are hailing
Cortes as a rising star on the political
landscape but in reality her views her
policy positions are actually downright
scary
look by the way he was a guy that was
supposed to take over for Nancy Pelosi
perhaps look very carefully this is the
future this is your modern Democratic
Party Cortez will likely win the general
election and a Democratic district is
pushing for let's see single-payer
universal health care universal jobs
government subsidized housing for
everybody
tuition free colleges she wants to
abolish ice and of course impeach
President Trump watch this would you
push for a trump impeachment should you
should you win well
I would I would I would support
impeachment I think that you know we
have the grounds to do it I think what
really we need to focus on is making
sure that we are advocating for the
policies to win in November but
ultimately I think that what we need to
kind of focus on is is ensuring that we
can you know when people break the law
potentially break the law that we have
to hold everyone accountable and that no
person is above that one the only
difference between the self-proclaimed
socialist that you just saw on the rest
of the Democratic Party is she's
actually more honest and as we have
shown you many times and we'll show you
all through this election season I'll
give you the agenda the Democratic Party
first they want to impeach 45 you just
heard it but they're not going to tell
you and of course they want to preserve
Obamacare and by the way Nancy Pelosi
company they're even saying this
publicly they want the tax cuts back
they want their crumbs returned and that
means two thousand dollars on average
per American family and obviously they
want open borders now we have a fifth
part of their democratic agenda that
we're adding for our list and that is to
destroy whoever the president picks to
replace Justice Kennedy on the US
Supreme Court I keep saying this is the
single most important midterm election
of our lifetimes now will president
Trump be able to assert his agenda for
the last two years of his first term or
are socialists will they be able to
impeach him obstruct him every step of
the way will we have another originalist
on the Supreme Court or will Democrats
be able to successfully block Kennedy's
successor do you really want these
people running the country let's take a
look a few years ago ideas that we
talked about were thought to be fringe
ideas radical ideas extremist ideas
those ideas are now mainstream I I just
don't even know why there aren't
of the country
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless
what's uncle time but for white women
who disappoint other white women one way
you get rid of Trump is a crashing
economy so please bring on the recession
that's a powerful ad from the RNC
perfectly encapsulating the mindset of
the left today and as you can see and
out really the peaceful people that they
claim to be their rhetoric is not just
wrong
it's now downright dangerous that have
more on the Democrats disgusting tactics
in a moment but first we do have
breaking developments surrounding Peter
struck as you know by now he was the
corrupt biased pro-hillary anti Trump
Trump hating FBI officials once tasked
with investigating Trump Russia
collusion and also was at the forefront
of helping to exonerate Hillary Clinton
of all the felonies and obstruction we
know she committed as it relates to our
server investigation today he was
apparently grilled but only behind
closed doors by two committees on
Capitol Hill and according to a brand
new report from Sarah Carter bad news
one congressman in attendance
representative Rhonda Santos said quote
it was struck he is full of it and he
kept hiding behind the quote classified
information excuse now fortunately we do
have one hopeful development today the
House Judiciary Committee tweeted quote
Peter struck will be interviewed first
in a closed-door deposition there will
be classified information to sort
through before a public hearing is held
a public hearing will be held this
public hearing is crucial you the
American people deserve to know how bias
at the highest levels of the FBI in fact
tainted what was the Hillary Clinton's
so-called investigation it's irrefutable
incontrovertible she committed crimes
and then the same people involved in
literally putting the fix in for her
were the beginnings began the witch-hunt
into of course so-called collusion and
the Muller investigation Peter struck
leads the page three other FBI
investigators Comey McCabe the ORS
Muller's merry band of Democratic donors
Jeanne Wray Andrew Weissman and so many
more we deserve answers you know why
because this was about influencing a
presidential election and literally
supporting and helping somebody we know
broke the law and then viciously trying
to destroy another candidate and Peter
struck must be held accountable and he
has questions to answer to the public
we have a lot to get to tonight